a former member of hunter thieves has
accused the org of not paying them
enough to eat this was huge and the
controversy only became bigger when 100
thieves ceo nadeshot responded to the
accusations in detail
let's break it down
[Music]
hey everyone it's liz before we get into
this i have to remind you as always the
like button the subscribe button and to
ring that notification bell so before we
get into all of this we need a little
bit of background hunter thieves is a
large esports organization founded by
nadeshot who is a former cod pro it's
grown to be pretty big with some of your
favorites like kai day as a part of the
org with courage and valkyrie as
co-owners in 2019 hundred thieves signed
the mob a group of content creators that
consisted of avalanche frosty mako and
classify but about two years later the
group had disbanded and parted ways with
hundred thieves that was over a year ago
and as far as we were aware there wasn't
any bad blood between the two parties
but this week we've learned that might
not have been the case on august 2019
frosty tweeted damn i missed the mob
house which seemed innocent enough but
it was his next tweets that started all
of this imagine we had enough money to
where we didn't have to stress over
where our next meal was coming from
could have done some big things but i
guess we'll never know a twitter user
responded to frosty saying imagine you
put all the effort in when you had an
org behind you twitch frosty responded
imagine we did but we were so broke that
we could literally not afford to do
anything that was worth filming when the
same twitter user asked why they didn't
simply ask the org for help frosty said
lmfao you have no idea how much we asked
got to point where was almost pathetic
but go ahead man blame the 20 year old
kids that had no idea what they were
doing instead of the 100 plus million
dollar predatory organization lol
responding to another user frosty
explained the financial situation saying
2 500 each and rent a month while only
getting paid 16.50 there were so many
days where we had to skip meals because
we couldn't afford to buy food unless we
begged our parents to send us money it
was truly a wonder why mako wanted to
leave the mob and move back with his
family and in another tweet me being
young and dumb put all the blame on
myself thinking about it now i see they
took complete advantage of us and these
tweets aren't even the half of it
remember when tifu complains about face
taking 80 of his sponsorship money
trying 95 lmfao so to tl dr this frosty
essentially accused the organization of
being predatory when it came to the
group's finances forcing them to live
any net negative when it came to money
after these pretty serious accusations
were levied nadeshot went live on his
twitch channel to respond to all of them
this is a pretty long vod about an hour
and a half long i watched it and break
down what i think the most important
parts are nate shot started off his
stream by talking about his humble
beginnings as a pro then moving forward
to build hundred thieves he said that he
wanted to bring on the mob but that they
weren't very big creators to begin with
the first accusation nadeshot responded
to was the housing one nature said the
group chose to live at a more expensive
house rather than a more affordable one
so we're gonna pay everybody 2 500 a
month
you have to live in la
you have to be here
we will help you find a home but
ultimately this is your responsibility
now if that didn't sit well with them
and that didn't feel right to them i
wish they would have told us that this
doesn't make sense or we can't
financially
make this work
but that was never the case that never
happened
and
when they were going and looking at
homes
they were the ones that chose
a ten thousand dollar
rent
home nadechot also spoke about the
budget the content group had and how it
was used to purchase things like mics we
also had a 2500
a month budget for them to use
for content
to to the best of my knowledge they used
that one month at one point to buy
all the microphones and equipment for
the mob cast nate shot then addressed
frosty's claim that hunter thieves took
95 percent of the sponsorship money that
is unequivocally undeniably without a
shadow of a doubt untrue
it is absolutely untrue there is no
basis for frosty to say this at one
point i have an email that the key terms
of these deals
that we bring to the mob
we would retain 85 percent of revenue
we did three deals for them
and all three two out of the three deals
they took home 65
of the revenue from that deal
okay 65 percent of the revenue from that
deal
one of those deals they made thirty
thousand dollars each
it was a two hundred thousand dollars
deal
they walked away with a hundred twenty
thousand dollars i believe it was
okay nate said also besides the home
they were paying for they made about 66
grand a year something i want to make
sure is understood that nate shot in his
stream kept talking about work ethic and
how hard he worked when he was younger
he compared it to the mob and said that
they did not put in the work day shot
also addressed the uno tournament tweet
where nadeshot said that they would not
have been there had it not been for
hundred thieves so that's pretty much
everything about frosty during the
stream nate shot talked about his
beginnings other teams his lcs team at
one point but this is pretty much the
most important parts of his stream
during or after this frosty tweeted that
basically this was all lies and that he
would be going live to clear everything
up frosty went live for even longer than
nadeshot so again i'm going to be
summarizing what i think the most
important parts are right now frosty
started history by saying that there
were requirements that they had to meet
for their living arrangements we could
not just move into any house we want we
literally we had to be
within 10 to 15 minutes of nate shot's
house now keep in mind nate shot's house
is in the center of los angeles right
one of the most expensive cities in the
world in one of the most expensive
neighborhoods in the most expensive city
in the world
the man's house is valued over 10
million dollars bro how are we supposed
to find a house that's within 10 to 15
minutes of that that's less than 10
grand frosty then went on to directly
dispute something nadeshot had said
regarding frosty only streaming 40 hours
a month frosty explained that he was
present on other members channels later
in the stream he said that their
internet was so bad that they would
combat this by appearing on each other's
streams so as not to overwhelm the one
wire that they had for a while frosty
then went on to explain the financial
situation which i'm going to summarize
as these bullet points he said that
there were definitely moments where
everyone in the house had negative
dollars in their bank accounts and could
not afford to buy food that the way they
had to use the hundred thieves content
budget was a sort of reimbursement form
that took weeks for them to receive
their money back that people knew they
were broke including nadeshot at one
point frosty claimed that hundred
thieves would not let them pursue a deal
with g-fuel since they were in talks
with a competitor that deal allegedly
never happened frosty also directly
disputed what nage hot had said about
them failing to deliver on sales deal
saying that one brand fireball loved
them that agency
is the one that my friend's the ceo of
i'm not going to name his name because i
don't want to throw him under the bus or
anything but he told me he told me that
fireball
loved us that we were their favorite
creators that they've worked with frosty
also made the claim that hunter thieves
would not let them sign with a talent
agency this one's a little bit odd to me
because going to current hundred these
member kai day's twitter bio
she's signed by united talent management
a couple of other points frosty hits on
the way is that they had bad internet
we're doing content for 100 thieves and
other members wouldn't do and that he
didn't tell nature about him skipping
meals because he did not want to move
back home so that's the important stuff
summarized i missed points that i didn't
think were super relevant but if you
want both sides of the story both of
these guys vods are on youtube this
whole drama raised many reactions out of
people including hundred thieves
co-owner courage who shared screenshots
of text messages and explained how he
was hurt by frosty's actions hunter
thief streamer brooke abe wrote quote i
am proud to call nayshot not only one of
my closest friends and also my boss he
goes above and beyond for the people
around him puts his heart and soul into
everything he does with the company one
of the best in the gaming community and
someone with the biggest heart for both
streams nick marks had responded to one
of frosty's earlier tweets saying that
this sounded familiar a shot in his live
stream response to frosty said he would
most likely be never speaking about the
situation between himself and mercs
former member of the mob classy actually
put out an entire thread at detailing
how hard he had worked as his only
response and that's about it most likely
this is the end of it but i did want us
to leave with something to think about
there have been lots of people praising
nadeshot offering the support to frosty
you name it but a lot of what this
conflict boils down to is the financial
aspect of esports and content creation
the nitty-gritty that a lot of us don't
want to see may be cool for us to see
the parties the merch the sponsorships
you name it but i think this tweet i'm
about to show summarizes how i feel
about all of this don't let the raucous
yas queening of nadeshot drain out the
open secret that esports teams are
wholly unsustainable at all levels and
everyone is living on borrowed time from
investor gambling so it scam city
baby we don't really get to see the
inside machinations of esports all too
often this week we got a little sneak
peek behind the scenes and as you can
tell
it isn't always pretty
[Music]
you